hola bienvenidos una vez más a esta
emisión a este programa este espacio
canadá en las américas café el
reencuentro que les proponemos cada
semana desde la sección en español de
radio canadá internacional una emisión
sería que no merecen ningún tipo de
sonrisas como las que veo aquí hoy
estamos en el estudio nuevamente un
equipo reducido de la sección en español
en este caso estamos aquí paloma
martínez ay qué tal vez eso que tal como
está paloma bien muy bien
rufo valencia hola luis paloma que tal
compañero a a ver que está en la técnica
arco y no saltar acompañado en la
técnica hoy porque está ausente en
nuestro compañero es llenarlo gimeno que
ha tenido esa bochornosa idea de partir
de vacaciones ya que tiene un excelente
español que tiene un excelente español
se iba mejorando le va mejorando de a
poco y mi nombre es luis labor taco les
recordamos como siempre nos pueden
seguir los saludamos a quienes nos
siguen a través de facebook live ese es
uno de los
tienen disponibles cada semana para
reencontrarse con esta con esta emisión
también nos pueden seguir a través del
canal de youtube y como es ya
tradicional por supuesto en nuestro
sitio en internet www r6 net punto o sea
donde cada viernes poco después de la
medida se encuentra disponible la
emisión para que ustedes puedan
disfrutarla
el viernes volverla a escuchar el sábado
y si quedan dudas el domingo el domingo
que fue lo que dijo y hasta y hasta se
dejamos un buen un buen tiempo el lunes
por la mañana sí hasta las 10 de la
mañana hora del este hasta los 10 de la
mañana efectiva medicina de vacaciones
pues están todos nuestros programas
archivados en nuestro sistema y 36
puntos o sea ayudan a encontrar todo lo
que hemos dicho y de dicho no podemos
decir nada en vano a tiene que estar muy
bien pensando exactamente en teoría
y más aún es el espacio son señales que
salen al espacio y no tienen la tiene el
límite es decir pero siempre se ha dicho
que la radio desde ese punto de vista es
más flexible yo creo que era ahora ya
una vez más más flexible que en los
medios impresos porque el número impreso
cuando vos publica vas a algún material
queda bajito tinta sobre papel y si
habías dicho alguna macana pac pero ya
no porque ahora la radio se transmite
por internet también y se queda guardada
ahí y ahí se quedan los archivos
digitales por dos siglos y bueno como lo
hicimos la semana pasada y como
habitualmente lo hace de rufo valencia
vamos a escuchar más de un tema musical
en esta emisión en este caso quienes
sigan la transmisión a través del sitio
web van a poder escuchar la música el
músico canadiense en a william que es un
músico de origen nativo pertenece a las
primeras naciones ese es el nombre
artístico de marc
el día en que nació en el norte de
manitoba que fue criado en el oeste de
la provincia de ontario y que comenzó a
interpretar música desde muy joven
tras graduarse en el programa de artes e
industria musical retornó a sanders bay
donde comenzó a colaborar con otros
músicos de las primeras naciones entre
otros galardones fue nominado como mejor
artista masculino al premio de la música
indígena canadiense tiene un estilo
musical muy particular que no se asemeja
al estilo musical al que estamos
acostumbrados
cuando hablamos de música indígena no es
tradicional típicamente el tradición
exactamente pero es nacido en el seno de
una comunidad de las primeras naciones y
muy orgullosos de pertenecer a las
mismas como decía quienes nos sigan a
través del sitio web van a poder
escuchar dos temas musicales uno de
ellos es open this eyes abre estos ojos
y el otro que vamos a poner al fin de
esta emisión waiting o esperando
dicen del bei es un lugar fantástico
porque al frente hay una isla una enorme
que se llama the sleep in chains el
gigante dormido y cuando lo ves
realmente parece un gigante de espaldas
durmiendo y hay los pueblos indígenas en
esa región tiene muchas leyendas sobre
ese gigante dormido me hace pensar en la
mujer dormida de méxico
junto con esta lista que también es una
leyenda indigencia y tiene justamente la
forma de una mujer durmiendo
se pone volcánicos son volcánicos más
son volcánicos
también mujer juntas siempre hay
volcanes
pero las montañas como tales
en el caso de méxico si son volcanes
claro es el popocatépetl y el lista si
los dos son volcanes
[Risas]
bueno
entonces bueno ya hemos comenzado de
hecho pero quiero decir antes de
meternos en la vorágine de la actualidad
como hacemos cada semana cuáles son los
temas fuera de lo común los temas no
convencionales los temas que les han
atraído la atención que les han
despertado curiosidad que les han
motivado la sonrisa que los han dejado
perplejos y una sonrisa triste porque es
porque pues tiene que ver con la
economía y tiene que ver con argentina
qué pasó que pues el peso está llegando
ya los casi 30 30 pesos por un dólar y
realmente es como volver a vivir lo que
ya se vivió cuando un país decide pese a
lo que es la experiencia que meterse con
la fm y uno nunca sale ganando porque es
como como esas casas de juego el póker
los casinos la casa siempre que hay un
autor mexicano que escribe un cuento
fantástico la casa siempre gana cuando
haces negocios con el fm y la casa
siempre gana
para argentina se quedó sin margen y ya
de una corrida de fondos increíble y no
hay forma de detener además de que dicen
lo que los analistas ya que el fm
no le no le permite
digamos hacer los gastos necesarios para
poder reactivar la economía y por otro
lado el sector privado que llegó al
gobierno cambió totalmente la
orientación económica con el presupuesto
de que una vez hechas las reformas de
corte neoliberal la inversión iba a
llegar pero no leo lo más triste de toda
esta historia pendular que se da todo el
tiempo en la pared sí pero es así porque
realmente son periodos que van y vienen
todo el tiempo es que pareciera ser que
hay vastos sectores de esa sociedad a la
cual yo pertenezco o que no vivo ahora
allí que no terminan de entender que ese
país daría para que viviese en todos los
sectores más que bien
pero parece ser que la cosa cuesta
entenderla y hoy en día como bien vos
decías se ha vuelto a modelos económicos
que ya han sido experimentados y no hace
tanto tiempo y que dieron como
resultados situaciones nefastas en
argentina todos tienen memoria y el
hecho fue conocido internacionalmente de
la crisis financiera que se desató en el
2001 que fue muy grave pero que desde
luego no fue la única que vivió ese país
y esa crisis fue resultado de políticas
económicas que en la base son similares
a las que se están aplicando hoy en día
ya indicadores pero también precisos por
ejemplo el que las compañías argentinas
están comprando sus propias acciones y
este es un indicador claro de una
recesión inminente porque es la única
forma que ellos tienen de poder
garantizar un cierto valor de retorno de
la inversión porque si dejan fuera del
control de las empresas entonces no soy
economista es mi
esta mirada así de encima pero si tus
acciones están en otras manos y pierden
valor no hay forma que puedas asegurarte
un cierto valor mantener un cierto valor
a lo que algo que has invertido entonces
es los economistas dicen que ese es un
signo claro de que argentina está
lamentablemente yendo a otra recesión y
el problema que cuando tú tienes una
economía que se tambalea día a día por
no decir ahora ahora que sólo hemos
vivido en argentina cuando yo era chico
se sentía como de hora en hora la
economía se iba agravando
eso no te permite programar
absolutamente nada de hecho de hipoteca
el futuro no tienes futuro posible con
una economía de ese tipo cuando tú no
puedes pensar en hacer una inversión en
algo importante como es comprar una casa
o invertir una suma de dinero importante
en lo que fuese porque no sabes si
hipotecar te te puede costar demasiado
caro en el futuro inmediato te quedas
sin futuro si algo aprendió un aquí es
que el hecho de que lo que hoy tiene un
precio el año que viene lo va a tener
igual o casi igual bueno yo te permite
hacer tus números programar crearte un
presupuesto que te permite decir bueno
voy a comprar una casa voy a renovar voy
a hacer esto eso lo otro en economías
como la que están viviendo en argentina
en este momento no puedes programar
absolutamente nada porque no sabes ni
qué va a hacer el valor de las cosas la
semana próxima
y entonces digamos ahí viene mi me la
está moliendo de ver la nariz a triste
que no aprendemos de la historia eso es
ese es el es lo que me sorprende y
constantemente y no es solamente el caso
de argentina yo creo que en américa la
américa latina y en muchas otras
regiones del mundo la situación es grave
y es que es grave y se repite y volvemos
a caer en los mismos lugares y volvemos
pero yo creo que yo quiero ser un poco
más optimista y decir que las mujeres al
poder no no necesariamente yo creo que
pueden ser hombres o mujeres quienes
estén al poder siempre y cuando tengan
una conciencia de
pues de lo que es importante yo creo que
si es importante la inversión de las
economías familiares particularmente
dentro de las familias es importante yo
creo que que es ahí donde nos podemos
concentrar porque la gente la gente no
tiene
garra en otros en otros aspectos de su
vida más que en la economía dentro de su
familia entonces yo creo que
la gente se puede organizar desde la
base y la gente puede hacer cosas en
pequeño y hacer cambios que tengan que
tengan importancia porque si no como el
cabello soy optimista eso creo que las
sociedades a pesar de que puedan cometer
y reiteraré errores evolucionan de todas
maneras y eso uno lo ve cada uno lo ve
con su sociedad yo estoy absolutamente
convencido que por ejemplo en mi caso la
sociedad argentina de hoy en día no es
la misma sociedad hace 20 30 o 40 años
atrás supongo que en méxico será
exactamente lo mismo en bolivia en otras
partes del mundo de la misma manera pero
claro ahí hay fenómenos que se producen
que ya dejaron su huella en otros
momentos y por eso yo decía y es
hincapié en la historia reciente han
dejado huellas recientes que tendrían
que estar frescas en la memoria pero
parecería ser que la memoria nuestra
cada vez tiene menos ubicado yo creo que
las sociedades cambian lentamente sin
embargo hay cosas que van mucho más
rápido y esas cosas que nos que nos van
a atrapar van a verlo hice una
entrevista recientemente sobre los
cambios climáticos en honduras y me doy
cuenta que
en términos amplios en términos macro va
a tener que reír y acomodarse cuando
todos los efectos de los cambios
climáticos se van a ver más directamente
porque parecen no relacionados pero si
se esperen las sociedades y las
economías van lentamente pero los
cambios climáticos van a todo lo que dan
entonces vamos a tener que acomodarnos
economías y sociedades muy rápido a
cambios que no van a hacer no pueden o
no podemos evitarlos
rufo tiene mensajes y aquí tenemos un
mensaje de antonio iniesta lópez a lo
antonio justo en este que es que
nosotros él dice buenas tardes desde
españa me alegra mucho de verles en
directo después de muchísimo tiempo
es la segunda vez que lo consigo pero
pues cuando ustedes emiten en directo yo
aún estoy en mi trabajo aprovecho ahora
que estoy de vacaciones
siempre les escucho desde el podcast me
alegro de verte paloma dice que en
nuestro amigo y verte paloma bienvenida
a tu casa veo que falta por ahí pablo y
la señora leonor a a ver si algún día
viene genera torrecilla mis grandes 51
para todos ustedes dice nuestro amigo
desde españa antonio ni está lópez pablo
y leonor está de vacaciones volverán
tuvo una pequeña lesión en su mano que
lo obligó a tomar licencia y aquí
tenemos otro mensaje de manfred
echevería él nos escribe que está de
ecuador y dice hoy 10 de agosto
independencia del ecuador bueno saludos
un generoso toman canelazos allá y
también que son los que son
son unos es un pequeño licor para el
invierno con mucha canela y un poco de
algún rico y caliente y tienen un ají de
panza fantástico no sé cómo moldea
mondongo la amplitud la amplitud de
conocimientos
en general también paloma tienes algún
tema en particular que te haces a modo
de atención esta semana bueno hay varios
temas que me llamaron la atención pero
digamos que si me voy un poco para lo
gracioso pero que al mismo tiene que al
mismo tiempo tiene que ver con lo médico
y con una legislación canadiense que va
a entrar en vigor ahora en el otoño el
17 de octubre particularmente es la
legalización de la marihuana en el país
de la del consumo incluso de la
producción de marihuana pues resulta ser
que esta legislación va a tener sus
efectos también en las mascotas
canadienses lo que va a producir también
no pero van a beneficiarse también
porque ustedes saben que aquí en canadá
desde el principio de los años 2000
la gente que tiene algún tipo de
afección médica que le causa mucho dolor
o que le causa mucha ansiedad puede
consumir productos marihuana de
diferentes formas ya sea fumada o comida
nuestra cursi marihuana no sé nunca he
probado pero lo que se dijo es que
pueden consumirlo para calmar un poco el
dolor calmar un poco la ansiedad la
gente con que tiene cáncer por ejemplo
entonces hay muchos médicos que 'las
para cierto tipo de enfermedades
prescriben marihuana o productos de
marihuana pues está explicada se aplica
comúnmente para el ipi lips yo también
exactamente entonces ahora resulta que
en estas fechas hay muchas compañías
productoras y desde productos de
marihuana de fabricantes de productos de
marihuana que están pensando en los
animalitos en las mascotas que también
sufren enfermedades y que van a poder
pronto o se espera que pronto van a
poder consumir productos de marihuana
juntos porque sospecho que no es que no
es un mero interés sanitario no es
seguramente que es un interés
debe haber mucho dinero hacer ahí porque
claro que como lo sabemos en canadá la
gente se ocupa y somos nosotros ejemplos
claros nos ocupamos mucho de nosotros
nuestros animalitos todos aquí tenemos
un perro en casa hizo parte de la
familia y es así también entonces en el
caso de que haya enfermedad yo tuve una
perrita muy enferma recientemente hace
un par de años y la vi sufrir tanto que
me hubiera gustado poderle dar algo para
aliviar el dolor porque los medicamentos
nos hacían afectar la cada vez más tanto
si hubieran comido una galleta de
marihuana
entonces si podemos ver la fotografía
que escogí para ilustrar este este
artículo que escribí una noticia es
justamente esa foto es la primera foto
hace pensar en que por lo menos ese pelo
ha conseguido un efecto muy placentero
con sus manos y no sé si sea un reflejo
real
de lo que puede ocurrir en la realidad
pero en todo caso allí se lo ve muy
placentero y creo que resume de muy
buena medida todo lo que desata está
esta posibilidad que yo creo y repito
las farmacéuticas es que vas a comprar
para mí bueno a partir del 17 de octubre
del 2018 rufo aquí en canadá para tu
perro o para ti va a ser aceptado muy
bien lo mal que no fumo yo por mi parte
quiero comentarles algo que
si está ocurriendo no exactamente en
este momento aquí en canadá aunque se
trata de una exposición que pasó hace un
tiempo atrás por canadá recuerdo que
estuvo aquí en la feria de exposiciones
cuando como se llama de la feria que
está en el puerto viejo paloma de la que
hablamos de su instante es en el centro
de ciencias demasiadas presencias de
montreal efectivamente creo que estuvo
allí esa exposición y yo la quise ver y
no alcancé a conseguir entradas pero es
una feria muy conocida que hace ya
muchos años en otras partes generó
controversia una feria en la que se
exponen cuerpos humanos y de animales
también y de animales también pero
específicamente éstas los cuerpos
humanos que son cuerpos plastinados
extendió la vida la vista
cc esto es la plastinación nadas no
exactamente es un proceso por el cual se
extraen todos los fluidos y la grasa del
cuerpo y se los reemplaza con una enzima
que crea un efecto de de plastinación o
plastificación
de ese cuerpo entonces incluso uno no
está muy seguro
frente a uno de esos cuerpos si se trata
de un cuerpo real o si se trata de una
reproducción muy lograda en plástico
pero no son cuerpos reales que han si
que han sido sometidos a este proceso
esto esta exposición se está llevando a
cabo en este momento en el reino unido y
en australia donde ha generado muchísima
controversia muchísimo debate e
inclusive hay presentaciones de tipo
judicial lo lleva adelante la empresa
royal bodies the exhibition que es
una empresa que pertenece a la persona
que promueve este procedimiento que es
el anatomista alemán gunther von hagens
la esposa de éste anatomista es que
entre gente a la empresa y quien además
se ocupa de la exhibición como como
negocio y la controversia ciudad
refrescado por el hecho de que en este
momento esa exposición presenta 20
cuerpos de personas de origen chino
la sospecha que tienen algunos abogados
en el reino unido y en australia y por
eso han realizado estas presentaciones
judiciales es que estas personas puedan
provenir de centros de detención en
china centros de detención en las que se
les ha obligado a trabajos forzosos o
incluso en los que se los puede haber
sometido a torturas y
ante la requisitoria de las autoridades
de documentación que
diese testimonio de que estos cuerpos
habían sido donados por la familia la
empresa no pudo presentar esa
documentación entonces el cbc tm que
éste anatomista alemán esté llevando a
cabo un negocio negro de tráfico de
cuerpos riesgoso porque como alguien se
puede arriesgar puede ser una cosa de
este hecho ya había sido denunciado y lo
mismo hacen muchos años e inclusive su
señal sí sí y su exhibición fue
prohibida por ejemplo por francia y
podía israel en francia israel les
prohibieron le prohibieron a este hombre
absolutamente presentar su exhibición en
gran bretaña no lo hicieron en australia
tampoco pero en este momento hay
muchísimos abogados que quieren que la
exhibición sea cerrada clausurada los
cuerpos se sean secuestrados y se lo
demande judicialmente roof ya que
tenemos un nuevo mensaje de nuestro
amigo manfred echeverría ya en
seguramente inquieto me imagino que éste
en quitó quizá en en guayaquil
ya él dice pues con ocasión del
independiente que vengan todos son
bienvenidos así que todos nos falta esa
alfombra mágica podemos ir hacer una
transmisión remota desde equipo adecuado
perfectos porque no nos gusta porque no
tenemos también un mensaje de nuestro
amigo de esta vez de colombia pulsamos
la frontera y estábamos julio ernesto
franco julio bienvenido gran bienvenido
si nosotros él dice un saludo desde
colombia así que españa colombia ecuador
países más bien pues yo así como estos
amigos los invitamos a todos los que nos
escuchan a todos los que nos siguen a
través de los sitios del sitio internet
de youtube facebook a que se contacte
utilicen esas tecnologías que existen
hoy en día que posibilitan ponerse en
contacto de manera instantánea lo que
les parecen los temas que estamos
presentando los tienen preguntas
preguntas dudas inquietudes sugerencias
saludos saludos porque no también
también podemos no sé si vamos a hacer
una referencia al respecto pero hoy
la mañana canadá se despertó un poco con
un evento que llamó la atención del
mundo entero fue este tiroteo en la
ciudad de frederick ton entonces si
tienen alguna duda sobre lo que sucedió
cómo sucedió nos escriben y les damos la
información que hay porque no hay
demasiada información aún pero hay
algunos detalles que podrían interesarle
si lo quieren efectivamente fue una
balacera en la ciudad de freddie thon en
nuevo brunswick en el este canadiense
hay cuatro muertos dos de ellos policías
se desconoce hasta ahora los motivos de
esa balacera pero es un hecho de esas
características que comienza a repetirse
con cada vez más a ciudades tranquilas
lo que ocurre un hecho de estas
características en un lugar en una zona
residencial a las 7 de la mañana
faltaban galletitas la única cosa es lo
que quiero mencionar el sospechoso fue
detenido y el sospechoso está en un
estado grave están atendiendo a los
médicos bueno vamos a una pequeña pausa
y ya volvemos con todos ustedes
hola aquí les habla marco castillo
productor músico brasileño que vive en
winnipeg y los invito a escuchar canadá
en las américas café de la radio canadá
internacional en la web
[Música]
noten si se es
y sabía
[Música]
no
y tienen medios y web
[Música]
vamos muy bien no hay
hoy
[Música]
me han hecho volver
van mal fly en la playa personas
[Música]
existe más
i
lewis a
[Música]
sí
soy pilar
y ahora
[Música]
[Aplausos]
aprendizaje
[Música]
el billón 19
richard
saborido
los dueños
[Música]
sí
su opinión
[Música]
ay
sí
con risas
[Música]
durante mis chistes
soria
y quién es
[Música]
y de operación
antes de ir a los temas que trabajamos
en la sección durante esta semana vamos
a ver algunos de los mensajes que nos
llegaron por escrito a través de
internet
de parte de nuestros oyentes palomas
quieres comenzar si tengo aquí un
comentario con respecto al tema elección
de lópez obrador en méxico tendrá
impacto en el mundo dos puntos john
ackerman es una entrevista con john
ackerman que hizo leonora chapman un
gran reto para un gran país que tiene
que no le queda otra que vivir de cerca
la lacra del narcotráfico y la
inmigración una pena porque la gente
mexicana es maravall maravillosa y no
firma esta persona solo tiene su
dirección electrónica que por supuesto
no voy a dar quien al aire pero bueno
esta persona comentaba en el reportaje
de leonora sobre la elección de lópez
obrador en méxico y aquí tenemos otro
mensaje desde mexico porque la dirección
extraer que termina con mx aunque luego
tiene una dirección chimel es maria
y ella
comenta una entrevista que hicimos con
el autor colombiano canadiense teobaldo
noriega quien presentó su libro entrada
a su libro humana impermanencia y dice
ella dice es seguido este señor desde
hace un rato y a pesar de ser discreto
me parece muy interesante su trabajo
muchas gracias maría por este mensaje
bueno yo por mi parte y sobre el tema de
inmigración y trabajo en canadá quiero
agradecer los mensajes que nos han hecho
llegar
eduardo abel arteaga galán ramón emilio
santos favio and go' maría que no ha
colocado su apellido ni otro dato carlos
rafael blandón gonzález jesús óscar de
colombia teodoro vegas' juan bernal juan
nicolás torres gómez y gerardo pérez
félix a todos ustedes muchísimas gracias
paloma otro mensaje otro comentario
sobre el tema nueva guía para refugiados
el lg vete q revolucionaria según
abogado canadiense jon y miguel cruz
caballero dice me gustaría contactarlos
espero sea posible
una pronta respuesta ya que tengo
ciertas dudas pues aquí en méxico el
problema de discriminación es muy
elevado pero me imagino que se refiere a
la gente el ggb de cv en méxico en un
estado conservador como lo es mérida
yucatán y documentándome me gustaría
poder emigrar a canadá soy un chico he
tenido serios problemas por mi
orientación sexuales pero ustedes me
puedan asesorar al respecto entonces
muchas gracias a johnny miguel cruz
caballero como ustedes saben los
procesos de inmigración se hacen a
través de las embajadas canadienses en
cada uno de sus países de origen los
valencianos y aquí tenemos un mensaje
que nos llega desde nuestra desde
justamente desde la costa del este
canadiense
desde nueva brunswick que justamente
hablábamos de lo que está pasando ahí es
un mensaje de william hill en abril
abril killen gracias por estar con
nosotros saludos ya dice hola desde cap
l nueva brunswick desafortunadamente a
mí me parece que hoy en día no queda
lugar no hay perdón de no haya peligro
la violen
dice y además de los riesgos de ataques
terroristas hacemos frente a un problema
de salud pública en todo parte ósea
problemas de salud mental dice entonces
seguramente refiriéndose a ese tiroteo
en fredericton entonces muchas gracias
en abril y otro mensaje también esta vez
desde nuestro desde argentina estamos
ecuador-colombia ahora vamos hasta
argentina y danielle camporini dice
saludos desde el mundo
danielle gusto el fiel daniel camporini
qué bueno que nos están siguiendo tanta
gente desde tantos lugares y ya que
llegamos para allá y bueno yo por mi
parte tengo un mensaje que nos envía
michael show sobre el tema de
latinoamericanos en que ve quiénes son y
nos dice sería interesante de saber el
impacto de raza de personas latinas en
quebec y el resto de canadá en
particular cuántas personas dicen que
son víctimas de discriminación porque no
son blancos este es el mensaje que nos
hace llegar michael joe sobre el tema
latinoamericanos en quebec quienes son
algún otro mensaje
quería comentar sobre ese tema creo que
se puede contactar a la gente que
organizó esta encuesta sobre los
latinoamericanos en quebec tal vez
sugerirles una próxima encuesta con
algunas preguntas específicas para tener
más detalles
de hecho creo que tiene una etapa de
esta investigación efectivamente sí y
además que es fácil encontrar
información vale está el sitio y la
información está disponible también el
sitio herencia de quebec y montreal uno
de los responsables del proyecto ese es
un profesor que ha estado con nosotros
en muchas entrevistas armonía
víctor armó no money que busquen habitar
money es quien está justamente llevando
adelante está ese trabajo víctor money
de origen argentino también si paloma si
tengo un comentario sobre el tema canadá
critica al resto de activistas sauditas
arabia saudita expulsa embajador
canadiense y federico sánchez dice creo
que el embajador canadiense debió ser
más prudente en sus declaraciones sobre
el tema estuve leyendo sobre el caso es
la primera vez que las señoras requerida
para investigación
no sé a qué señor está haciendo
referencia pero no fue el embajador
canadiense que hizo comentarios sobre
los derechos humanos o el respeto de los
activistas de derechos humanos en arabia
saudita fue la representante de
relaciones exteriores del país que es
cristiana cristiá fila
freeland y ella fue la que hizo los
comentarios y el gobierno canadiense se
mantiene en su postura ellos dicen que
siempre estarán a favor de aquellos que
defiendan los derechos humanos y que era
el resto de ciertas personas en una
manifestación particularmente mujeres y
la hermana de un de un conocido bloguero
no de origen no canadiense pero dije en
saudita pero cuya familia vive aquí en
canadá esta fue también arrestada
entonces eso fue criticado por el
gobierno canadiense y pues claro las
relaciones están tensas entre arabia
saudita canadá desde entonces desde el
domingo pasado grupo algún mensaje que
quieras leer pues y aquí tenemos un
mensaje muy bien gastado bien
estructurado de rodrigo berger rodrigo
vega gamarra y cuervos nos exhibe desde
desde colombia y él es muy estructurado
es sucesivamente una carta que como las
cartas de antaño no en que vayan varios
párrafos y un argumento bien
desarrollado y él justamente comenta una
noticia un que dice que el fm y advierte
que conflictos comerciales hacen
vulnerable eeuu
y rodrigo vega dice el fmi dice que
debido a la guerra de aranceles los eeuu
pueden sufrir una de esas desaceleración
en sus exportaciones
eso no es determinante mientras se
asegure el mercado nacional para la
industria nacional y las empresas
nacionales se consoliden y crezcan y
queden en capacidad de producir para la
exportación de bienes de buena calidad y
a precios competitivos es una cuestión
de tiempo y de espera mientras se
consolida internamente la economía
nacional estadounidense en una especie
de autarquía la política proteccionista
de washington es un apoyo del gobierno
de eeuu a su industria nacional todo
gobierno sensato tiene el deber de
proteger sus fuentes internas de empleo
y de producción de no ser así los países
entrarían en recesión con una población
desocupada flotante mantenida por los
subsidios estatales por la economía
informal y por el delito además se
convierten en países compradores e
improductivos que vivirían endeudados
para poder subsistir si bien es cierto
que los que la inversión de capitales
fortalece a las empresas
es cierto que la esencia de la
existencia de las plantas productivas
mismas con la ciencia y la tecnología al
servicio de ellas para su
retroalimentación pues si el capital
aparte de ser especulativo por sí solo
no se multiplica él dice finalmente dice
la fm que se elevaría la incertidumbre y
se dañaría la inversión la duda siempre
ha estado y la inversión es dañada por
múltiples factores crisis política
desastres naturales etcétera que el
hombre común no alcanza a controlar en
lo económico del ser humano siempre he
vivido una especie de fatalidad relativa
de la cual siempre ha sabido salir hoy
por hoy todo parece apuntar al fracaso
de la política neoliberal de apertura
económica el break si lo confirma dice
finalmente en esta larga carta rodrigo
vega gamarra y cuervo desde colombia
bueno ahí está muy bien yo tengo por mi
parte y antes de pasar a los temas de la
semana un mensaje que nos envía willy y
fabián y bautista sobre el tema médico
canadiense dice que la diabetes tipo 2
es curable nos dice willy que es de
bolivia preocupante el índice
en santa cruz de bolivia si pudiera
orientar más a nuestra población vía
este medio
o tal vez mediante vídeos clips bueno
habría que contactarse con el médico
directamente para para proponerle a él
en todo caso y ver si está interesado
realmente en enviar vídeos o cualquier
tipo de sugerencia que les pudiese
ayudar a superar esto que ustedes de
willy señala como un índice alto de
diabéticos en santa cruz de bolivia
porque será eso rufo porque tanto
diabético en esa zona porque es lo que
puede lo que es lo que me sorprende lo
que me sorprendió mucho en santa cruz
una ciudad de una la ciudad más grande
en población en bolivia es que nunca
había visto botellas tan grandes de
cocacola así son casi de dos litros y
medio tres litros unas cosas enormes y
no hay no hay circunstancia en la cual
esté ausente es decir se consumen todas
en todo momento en todas partes y pues
seguramente han habido estudios en
méxico me acuerdo que demostraban
justamente que dejar de tomar este tipo
de bebidas azucaradas le reducía a
consecuencias como la diabetes entonces
es claro que hay que también recordar
que en algunas regiones no sé si en
bolivia es lo mismo
en algunas regiones de méxico es más
barato comprar coca cola que comprar
leche por ejemplo como cupo incluso
botellas de agua y así sin duda yo creo
que no hay problemas de agua porque en
la región amazónica entonces hay
accesibilidad de agua
hay ríos como pasan por la ciudad y
también seguramente también es la dieta
no porque hay muchos pasteles son muy
ricos muy dulces a es fantástico y una
cosa que es interesante y en santa cruz
alas es una tradición que me gusta mucho
hay hay todavía hay salones de té
en que tú vas a las cuatro o cinco de la
tarde y tienes una panoplia de
exquisiteces ahí los cuñas por ejemplo
que es unos pasitos de queso tienen
tradición inglesa severe a las cuatro
bueno yo creo que yo creo que habían
todos todos todas las culturas siempre
tienen tienen los ritos cotidianos para
estar juntos entonces esa sobremesa
clara en el célebre almuerzo de domingo
familiar que si no dije no tienes que
estar bueno tallarines el tuco siendo
que se nos quedan menos de diez minutos
para terminar nuestra emisión es decir
el tiempo si nos va como agua entre los
dedos pues para que todo como como
tortilla tan bueno dejemos la comida del
agua
cuáles son los temas en los que hemos
estado trabajando durante esta semana me
refiero a los temas que ustedes quieren
proponer es en prioridad dentro de todos
los que hemos trabajado esta semana a
aquellos que le proponen en prioridad
nuestros oyentes a nuestro público en
general para que accedan prontamente a
los mismos quien quiere comenzar pues
vayamos con esto
rufo podemos intercambiar el lugar bueno
pues freddy villanueva villanueva murió
hace 10 años hice un reportaje y una
entrevista sobre está por la muerte de
este chico dediquen a aquella época
tenía 18 años y que murió por uno por
tiros de un policía un policía de las
del servicio de policía de montreal
entonces ocurre en montreal norte en una
zona de montreal que es una de las zonas
más pobres del canadá completo no
solamente de montreal que tiene índices
de desempleo muy bajos niveles de perdón
índices de desempleo muy altos
dificultades económicas importantes
entonces estuve conversando con
alejandra sara méndez quien tenía 20
años cuando sucedió la muerte de freddy
y que conoce muy bien este barrio de
montreal norte
alejandra me contó sus me habló de sus
recuerdos claros sobre el evento como
tal me dijo también que no habían
cambiado mucho las cosas desde aquella
época que la discriminación que la
desigualdad que el desempleo siguen
siendo parte de la realidad cotidiana de
los jóvenes y de las familias que son en
mayoría inmigrantes en esa región de la
ciudad hay un giro no porque no va a
montar el norte y parece una zona
olvidada de monte exactamente entonces
cuando entonces ella explica toda esta
realidad después de lo que es su cuna
porque ella creció en montreal norte
entonces conoce muy bien entonces es
interesante escuchar a una joven que
tiene muchas muchas ganas de que cambien
las cosas explicar este evento y
explicar cómo afectó a la población
local el que este joven que no estaba
haciendo nada más jugar dados con unos
amigos en el parque cuando res cuando
fue digamos hubo una intervención
policial que fue mal cayó 6 y yo mal
hubo una una de las personas no quiso
entregar los papeles bueno entonces se
armó un una situación tensa entre los
policías y los chicos que resultó en una
fatalidad en la muerte de freddy
villanueva entonces diez años de esta
muerte y lo que eso significa para mí
y para la gente los inmigrantes las
comunidades inmigrantes
yo recuerdo muy vivamente la conmoción
que creó el caso en toda la sociedad y
parece mentira que hayan pasado diez
años rufo tenías un mensaje creo si aquí
hay alguien que apoya injustamente que
nos envió un breve mensaje después de
saludarnos de monroe que nos dice y si
no creo que exista hoy un país con una
política tan corrupta como la argentina
y punto y entonces ayer estaba yo
también en esa parte monte al norte y
pude también ver justamente esos
elementos y ya esta semana habrá un
reportaje también sobre uno que puede
conversar con la madre de freddy
villanueva y es muy complicada es
compleja la situación difícil y lilian
villanueva es que estuvo presente en
todos los eventos relacionados con su
hijo el tema que propongo esta semana es
justamente una pregunta que nada tiene o
no derecho a pronunciarse sobre los
derechos humanos en arabia saudita
porque eso fue lo que irritó a la
monarquía que se rige a partir de la ley
de la sharía y además de
de expulsar al embajador canadiense le
dieron 24 horas para beso dieta también
decidió retirar a los estudiantes
saudíes en canadá retirar a los
pacientes saudíes que están recibiendo
atención médica acá y también está en
tela de juicio es está casi en
a saber si continúan este negocio de 15
mil millones dólares por la compra de
vehículos de combate que el ejército que
canadá estaba vendiendo a arabia saudita
entonces el profesor daniel turp quien
es un enseña derecho a la fruta en olla
de montreal en la facultad de derecho el
dice concretamente que canadá si tiene
derecho dicen podemos inmiscuirnos
porque justamente desde 1948 que nada
participó en la redacción misma de la
declaración de naciones unidas o los
derechos humanos y los países si tienen
derecho a pronunciarse sobre los
derechos humanos en otros países ese es
en concreto su respuesta entonces hay
más detalles sobre sobre el contexto de
esta de este enfrentamiento y el
concreto es que básicamente arabia
saudita en la impresión que hay es que
arabia saudita la compra de esos es con
esos carros militares lo que en el fondo
cree es el silencio de canadá en materia
de derechos humanos en esa en esa
monarquía
bueno el reportaje está disponible ya en
el sitio en internet quien está
interesado en el tema invitado entonces
para que acceda al mismo yo por mi parte
les propongo una entrevista que realicé
ligado al tema del time el time de h&m
team en español es un
el telescopio gigante ubicado en la
provincia de columbia británica en el
oeste canadiense que se está dedicando a
estudiar diversos tipos de señales
provenientes del espacio exterior de la
profundidad del espacio exterior
este time que es el canadian hidrógeno
intensity mapping experiment el
experimento canadiense para el mapeo de
la intensidad del hidrógeno se propone
crear un mapa del hidrógeno en el
universo el hidrógeno es el elemento de
mayor presencia en todo el universo y
emite ese gas señales sonoras que son
captadas por este telescopio y al
estudiar los rastros más antiguos de
hidrógeno en universos más lejanos
también se puede hacer una se puede
trazar un mapa de cuál sido la expansión
que ha seguido el universo y prever cuál
va a ser la expansión que seguirá en el
futuro que es un tema que está
comenzando a hablarse un giro por parte
de los científicos porque se sabe que
américa siendo y en algún caso
yo hablé con un científico
en la universidad mayor y el salir
y el tema saltó esta semana sobre todo
cuando se empezó a hablar del estudio de
comunicaciones de una radio sido
pendientes del espacio exterior
mensajes enviados en el exterior que
está intentando comunicar le pregunté a
uno pero dejó abierta la puerta porque
he hecho
de las emanaciones mensaje
y por supuesto
antes de ese mensaje
[Música]
este saludo y pregunta dónde podemos
consultar los reportajes sobre el freddy
villanueva
está disponible para menos tiempo
agradecemos la presencia de prometimos a
todos estar aquí una vez más la semana
próxima muchas gracias a todos y os
dejamos entonces con la música
dyn
[Música]
también se quiera
y lo digo
tu cuerpo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y
[Música]
donde los actores entre otros galardones
fue nominado como mejor artista
masculino
musical
indígena
sí
[Música]
dormido cuando realmente parece un
gigante de espaldas durmiendo
los perros indígenas en esa región
tienen muchas leyendas sobre ese gigante
sólidos me hace pensar en la mujer
dormida de méxico
junto con esto que también es una
leyenda indígena y tiene justamente la
forma de una mujer durmiendo exacto
volcánicos son volcánicos mar son
volcánicos el camino mujer juntas
siempre hay volcanes
pero las montañas como tales
en el caso de méxico si son volcanes el
popocatépetl y el listas y los dos son
volcanes
[Música]
fue bueno
entonces bueno ya hemos comenzado de
hecho pero esto decir antes de meternos
en la vorágine de la actualidad como
hacemos cada semana cuáles son los temas
fuera de lo común los temas no
convencionales los temas que les han
atraído la atención que les han
despertado curiosidad que les han
motivado la sonrisa que los han dejado
perplejos y tenía una sonrisa triste
porque
porque es porque inhibe con la economía
y tiene que ver con argentina qué pasó
que pues el peso está llegando a los
casi 30 30 pesos por un dólar y
realmente es como volver a vivir lo que
ya se vivió cuando un país decide
esa es la experiencia que meterse con la
fm y uno nunca sale ganando porque es
como esas casas de juego el póker los
casinos la casa siempre que anna yo
autor mexicano que escribe un cuento
fantástico la casa siempre gana cuando
haces una cosa es con el fm y la casa
siempre gana y ahora la argentina se
quedó sin margen y ya de una corrida de
fondos increíble y no hay forma de
detener además de que dicen los lo que
los analistas ya que la fm
no lee no le permite
digamos hacer los gastos necesarios para
poder reactivar la economía y por otro
lado los ese todo privado que llegó al
gobierno cambió totalmente la
orientación económica con el presupuesto
de que una vez hechas las reformas de
corte neoliberal la inversión iba a
llegar pero no llegó lo más triste de
toda esta historia pendular que se da
todo el tiempo en las esquinas por eso
sí pero es así porque realmente son
periodos que van y vienen todo el tiempo
es que pareciera acerca
vastos sectores de esa sociedad a la
cual yo pertenezco que no vi por allí
que no terminan de entender que ese país
daría para que viviese en todos los
sectores más que bien
pero parece ser que la cosa cuesta
entenderla y hoy en día como bien vos
decías se ha vuelto a modelos económicos
que ya han sido experimentados y no hace
tanto tiempo y que dieron como
resultados situaciones nefastas en
argentina todos tienen memoria y el
hecho fue conocido internacionalmente de
la crisis financiera que se desató en el
2001 que fue muy grave pero que desde
luego no fue la única que dio ese país y
esa crisis fue resultado de políticas
económicas que en la base son similares
a las que se están aplicando hoy en día
ya indicadores pero también precisos por
ejemplo el que las compañías argentinas
están comprando sus propias acciones y
este es un indicador claro de una
recesión inminente porque es la única
forma que ellos tienen de poder
garantizar un cierto valor de retorno de
la inversión porque si dejan fuera del
control de las empresas entonces no sea
economista es vil
esta mirada así de encima pero si tus
acciones están en otras manos pierden
valor no hay forma que puedas asegurarte
un cierto valor mantener un cierto valor
a lo que algo que has invertido entonces
ese los economistas dicen que ese es un
signo claro de que argentina está
lamentablemente yendo a otra recesión y
el problema que cuando tú tienes una
economía que se tambalea día a día por
no decir ahora ahora que sólo hemos
vivido en argentina cuando yo era chico
se sentía como de hora en hora la
economía se iba agravando y eso no te
permite programar absolutamente nada de
hecho te hipoteca el futuro no tienes
futuro posible con una economía de ese
tipo cuando tú no puedes pensar en hacer
una inversión en algo importante como es
comprar una casa o invertir una suma de
dinero importante en lo que fuese porque
no sabes si hipotecar te te puede costar
demasiado caro en el futuro inmediato te
quedas sin futuro si algo aprendió un
aquí es que
y el hecho de que lo que hoy tiene un
precio el año que viene lo va a tener
igual o casi igual bueno eso te permite
hacer tus números programar crearte un
presupuesto que te permite decir bueno
voy a comprar una casa voy a renovar voy
a hacer esto vas a lo otro en una
economía es como la que están viviendo
en argentina en este momento no puedes
programar absolutamente nada porque no
sabes qué va a hacer el valor de las
cosas la semana próxima
y ya entonces digamos ahí viene mi me la
está molière de ver la risa triste que
no aprendemos de la historia eso es es
el algo que me sorprende constantemente
y no es solamente el caso de argentina
yo creo que en américa la américa latina
y en muchas otras regiones del mundo la
situación es grave y es que es grave y
se repite y volvemos a caer en los
mismos lugares y volvemos pero yo creo
que yo quiero ser un poco más optimista
y decir que las mujeres al poder no no
necesariamente y yo creo que pueden ser
hombres o mujeres quienes estén al poder
siempre y cuando tengan una conciencia
de
pues de lo que es importante yo creo que
si es importante la inversión de las
economías familiares particularmente
dentro de las familias es importante yo
creo que que es ahí donde nos podemos
concentrar porque la gente la gente no
tiene
garra en otros en otros aspectos de su
de su vida más que en la economía dentro
de su familia entonces yo creo que
la gente se puede organizar desde la
base y la gente puede hacer cosas en
pequeño y hacer cambios que tengan que
tengan importancia porque si no como
ellos pero que las sociedades a pesar de
que puedan cometer y reiterar errores
evolucionan de todas maneras y eso uno
lo ve cada uno donde con su sociedad yo
estoy absolutamente convencido que por
ejemplo en mi caso la sociedad argentina
de hoy en día no es la misma sociedad de
20 30 ó 40 años atrás
supongo que méxico será exactamente la
misma en bolivia en otras partes del
mundo de la misma manera pero claro ahí
hay fenómenos que se producen que ya
dejaron su huella en otros momentos y
por eso yo decía y es hincapié en la
historia reciente han dejado huellas
recientes que tendrían que estar frescas
en la memoria pero parecería ser que la
memoria nuestra cada vez y no menos
ubicada yo creo que las sociedades
cambian lentamente sin embargo hay cosas
que van mucho más rápido y esas cosas
que nos que nos van a atrapar van a
verlo hice una entrevista recientemente
sobre los cambios climáticos en honduras
y me doy cuenta que
la economía de en términos amplios en
términos macro va a tener que
reacomodarse cuando todos los efectos de
los cambios climáticos se van a ver más
directamente porque parecen no
relacionados pero si se esperen las
sociedades y las economías van
lentamente pero los cambios climáticos
van a todo lo que dan entonces vamos a
tener que acomodarnos economías y
sociedades muy rápido a cambios que no
van a ser no puede no podemos evitar los
flujos de un mensaje si aquí tenemos un
mensaje de antonio iniesta lópez aldo
antonio justo en este que es el que
nosotros él dice buenas tardes desde
españa me alegra mucho de verles en
directo después de muchísimo tiempo es
la segunda vez que lo consigo pero pues
cuando ustedes emiten en directo yo aún
estoy en mi trabajo aprovecho ahora que
estoy de vacaciones
siempre les escuchó desde el podcast me
alegro de verte paloma dice que es
nuestro amigo y verte paloma bienvenida
a tu casa veo que falta por ahí pablo y
la señora leonor a a ver si algún día
viene de la torrecilla mis grandes 51
para todos ustedes dice nuestro amigo
desde españa antonio iniesta lópez pablo
y leonor está de vacaciones y volverán
en una pequeña lesión en su mano del
obligó a tu mano dice enseguida y aquí
tenemos otro mensaje de manfred
echevería él nos escribe más el que está
llamado de ecuador y dice hoy 10 de
agosto independencia del ecuador bueno
saludos
un general toman canelazos allá y
también son generación unos es un
pequeño licor para el invierno con mucha
canela y un poco de algo me dijo siti
caliente y tienen un ají de panza
fantástico mondongo
la actitud de conocimiento
en general también paloma tienes algún
tema en particular que te llamó la
atención esa semana bueno hay varios
temas que me llamaron la atención pero
digamos que si me voy un poco para luego
gracioso pero que al mismo tiempo al
mismo tiempo tiene que ver con lo médico
y con una legislación canadiense que va
a entrar en vigor ahora en el otoño el
17 de octubre particularmente es la
legalización de la marihuana en el país
de la del consumo incluso de la
producción de marihuana pues resulta ser
que esta legislación va a tener sus
efectos también las mascotas canadienses
lo que va a producir también no pero van
a beneficiarse también porque ustedes
saben que aquí en canadá desde el
principio de los años 2000 la gente que
tiene algún tipo de afección médica
qué le causa mucho dolor que le causa
mucha ansiedad puede consumir productos
marihuana de diferentes formas ya sea
fumada o comida muy buena no sé nunca he
probado pero lo que dijo es que pueden
consumirlo para calmar un poco el dolor
calmar un poco la ansiedad la gente con
que tiene cáncer por ejemplo entonces
hay muchos médicos que 'las para cierto
tipo de enfermedades y prescriben
marihuana o productos de marihuana
cualificada se aplica comúnmente para el
impide pge yo también exactamente
entonces ahora resulta que en estas
fechas hay muchas compañías productoras
y de productos de marihuana de
fabricantes de productos de marihuana
que están pensando en los animalitos en
las mascotas que también sufren
enfermedades y que van a poder pronto o
se espera que pronto van a poder
consumir productos de marihuana porque
no es que no es un mero interés
sanitario no es seguramente que es un
interés económico
a ver mucho dinero hacer ahí porque
claro que como lo sabemos en canadá la
gente se ocupa y somos nosotros ejemplos
claro nos ocupamos mucho de nuestros
animalitos todos aquí tenemos un perro
en casa y son parte de la familia y es
así también entonces en el caso de que
haya enfermedad yo tuve una perrita muy
enferma recientemente hace un par de
años y la vi sufrir tanto que me hubiera
gustado poderle dar algo para aliviar el
dolor porque los medicamentos nos hacían
afectar la cada vez más tal que se
hubiera comido una galleta de marihuana
no sé si podemos ver la fotografía que
escogí para para ilustrar este este
artículo que escribí una noticia es
justamente va a salir esa foto esa
primera foto hace pensar en que por lo
menos ese perro ha conseguido un efecto
muy muy placentero con su look con sus
marihuana no sé si yo sé si sea un
reflejo real
de lo que puede ocurrir en la realidad
pero en todo caso allí se ve muy
placentero y creo que había sume de muy
buena medida todo lo que desata está
esta posibilidad que yo creo y repito
para mí bueno a partir del 17 de octubre
del 2018 rufo aquí en canadá para tu
perro o para ti va a ser aceptado
yo por mi parte quiero comentarles algo
que sí está ocurriendo no exactamente en
ese momento aquí en canadá aunque se
trata de una exposición que pasó hace un
tiempo atrás por canadá recuerdo que
tuvo aquí en la feria de exposiciones
cuando como se llama de la feria que
está ahí en el puerto viejo paloma de la
quedamos de su instante es en el centro
de ciencias demasiado presencias de
montreal efectivamente creo que estuvo
allí esa exposición y yo la quise ver y
no alcancé a conseguir entradas pero es
una feria muy conocida que hace ya
muchos años en otras partes generó
controversia
una feria en la que se exponen cuerpos
humanos y de animales también y de
animales también pero específicamente
estas dos de los cuerpos humanos que son
cuerpos plastinados estén en la vida
si esto es la plastinación nada no
exactamente es un proceso por el cual se
extraen todos los fluidos y la grasa del
cuerpo y se los reemplaza con una enzima
que crea un efecto de la plastinación
plastificación de ese cuerpo entonces
incluso no está muy seguro cuando está
frente a uno de esos cuerpos si se trata
de un cuerpo real o si se trata de una
reproducción muy lograda en plástico
pero no son cuerpos reales que han si
que han sido sometidos a este proceso
esto esta exposición se está llevando a
cabo en este momento en el reino unido y
en australia donde ha generado muchísima
controversia muchísimo debate inclusive
presentaciones de tipo judicial lo lleva
adelante la empresa real bodies de
exhibición que es una empresa que
pertenece a la persona que promueve este
procedimiento que es el anatomista
alemán gunther von hagens la esposa de
éste anatomista es quien regentea la
empresa y quien además se ocupa de la
exhibición como como negocio y la
controversia ciudad refrescado por el
hecho de que en este momento esa
exposición presenta 20 cuerpos de
personas de origen chino y él la
sospecha que tienen algunos abogados en
el reino unido y en australia y por eso
han realizado estas presentaciones
judiciales es que estas personas puedan
provenir de centros de detención en
china centros de detención en las que se
les ha obligado a trabajos forzosos e
incluso en los que se los puede haber
sometido a torturas y
ante la requisitoria de las autoridades
de documentación que
10 de testimonio de que estos cuerpos
habían sido donados por la familia la
empresa no pudo presentar esa
documentación entonces el cbc tm que
éste anatomista alemán esté llevando a
cabo un negocio negro de tráfico de
cuerpos riesgoso porque como alguien se
puede arriesgar cuál será una cosa de
este derecho ya había sido denunciado y
ahora mismo hace muchos años e inclusive
su misma señal sí sí y su exhibición fue
prohibida por ejemplo por francia y
porque israel en francia israel les
prohibieron le prohibieron a este hombre
absolutamente presentar su exhibición en
gran bretaña no lo hicieron en australia
tampoco pero en este momento hay
muchísimos abogados que quieren que la
exhibición sea cerrada clausurada los
cuerpos
sean secuestrados y se lo demande
judicialmente roof si ex tenemos un
nuevo mensaje de nuestro amigo manfred
echeverría ya seguramente inquieto me
imagino que se quitó quizá en en
guayaquil
ya él dice pues con ocasión del
independiente cuando dice vengan todos
son bienvenidos así que todo no nos
falta esa alfombra mágica podemos hacer
no transmisión remota desde equipo
adecuado perfecto sí por qué no
porque tenemos también un mensaje de
nuestro amigo de esta vez desde colombia
usamos la frontera y estábamos julio
ernesto franco julio bienvenido gran
bienvenidos y nosotros él dice un saludo
desde colombia así que españa colombia
ecuador
qué países más bien pues yo así con
nuestros amigos los invitamos a todos
los que nos escuchan a todos los que nos
siguen a través de los sitios del sitio
internet de youtube facebook a que se
contacte utilice esas tecnologías que
hoy en día que posibilitan ponerse en
contacto de manera instantánea sino que
les parecen los temas que estamos
presentando los tienen preguntas
preguntas dudas inquietudes sugerencias
saludos saludos porque no también
también podemos no sé si vamos a hacer
un referencia al respecto pero hoy por
mañana a canadá se despertó un poco con
un con un evento que llamó la atención
del mundo entero fue este tiroteo en la
ciudad de frederick ton entonces si
tiene alguna duda sobre lo que sucedió
cómo sucedió nos escriben y les damos la
información que hay porque no hay
demasiada información aún pero hay
algunos detalles que podrían interesarle
si lo quiere efectivamente fue una
evaluación en la ciudad de freddie thon
en el bronx week en el este canadiense
hay cuatro muertos dos de ellos policías
se desconoce hasta ahora los motivos de
esa balacera pero es un hecho de esas
características que comienza a repetirse
con cada vez más a ciudad tranquilo
que ocurre un hecho de estas
características en un lugar en una zona
residencial a las 7 de la mañana la
única cosa es lo que quiero mencionar el
sospechoso fue detenido y el sospechoso
está en un estado grave están atendiendo
a los médicos bueno vamos a una pequeña
pausa y ya volvemos con todos ustedes
aquí les habla marco castillo productor
músico brasileño que vive en winnipeg y
los invito a escuchar canadá en las
américas café de la radio canadá
internacional en la web
[Música]
bueno esa es la invitación para que nos
sigan escuchando y les recuerda que nos
sigan a través del sitio en internet que
podrán escuchar música del artista
cadencia en a william durante esta
emisión
antes de ir a los temas
que trabajamos en la sección durante
esta semana vamos a ver algunos de los
mensajes que nos llegaron por escrito a
través de internet de parte de nuestros
oyentes palomas que les comenzará si
tengo aquí un comentario con respecto al
tema elección de lópez obrador en méxico
tendrá impacto en el mundo dos puntos
john ackerman es una entrevista con john
ackerman que hizo leonora chapman un
gran reto para un gran país que tiene
que no le queda otra que vivir de cerca
la lacra del narcotráfico y la
inmigración una pena porque la gente
mexicana es marabá y maravillosa y no
firma esta persona solo tiene su
dirección electrónica que por supuesto
no voy a dar sean al aire pero bueno
esta persona comentaba en el reportaje
de leonora sobre la elección de lópez
obrador en mexico ya que tenemos otro
mensaje desde mexico porque la dirección
extraer que termina con mx
aunque luego tiene una dirección chimel
es maría y ella
y comenta una entrevista que hicimos con
el autor colombiano canadiense teobaldo
noriega quien presentó su libro entrada
a su libro humana impermanencia y dice
ella dice es seguido este señor desde
hace un rato y a pesar de ser discreto
me parece muy interesante su trabajo
muchas gracias maría por este mensaje
cuando yo por mi parte y sobre el tema
de inmigración y trabajo en canadá
quiero agradecer los mensajes que nos
han hecho llegar
eduardo abel arteaga galán ramón emilio
santos favio mango maría que no ha
colocado su apellido ni otro dato carlos
rafael blandón gonzález jesús óscar de
colombia
teodoro vegas' juan bernal juan nicolás
torres gómez y gerardo pérez félix a
todos ustedes muchísimas gracias paloma
otro mensaje otro comentario sobre el
tema nueva guía para refugiados el lg
vete q revolucionaria según abogado
canadiense jon y miguel cruz caballero
dice me gustaría contactarlos espero sea
posible
una pronta respuesta ya que tengo
ciertas dudas pues aquí en méxico el
problema de discriminación es muy
elevado me imagino que se refiere a la
gente el lg de cv en méxico en un estado
conservador como lo es mérida yucatán y
documentándome me gustaría poder emigrar
a canadá soy un chico he tenido serios
problemas por mi orientación sexuales
pero ustedes me puedan asesorar al
respecto entonces muchas gracias a joni
mitchell cruz caballero como ustedes
saben los procesos de inmigración se
hacen a través de las embajadas
canadienses en cada uno de sus países de
origen los cuales si aquí tenemos un
mensaje que nos llega desde nuestra
desde justamente desde la costa del este
canadiense
desde nueva versión justamente
hablábamos de lo que está pasando allí
es un mensaje de william hill en abril
abril killen gracias por estar con
nosotros un saludo saludos ya dice hola
desde cat pl nueva brunswick
desafortunadamente a mí me parece que
hoy en día no queda lugar
no hay película donde no haya peligro de
violencia 16 además de los riesgos de
ataques terroristas hacemos frente a un
problema de salud pública en todo parte
ósea problemas de salud mental dice y
entonces seguramente refiriéndose a ese
tiroteo en fredericton entonces muchas
gracias giren abril y otro mensaje
también esta vez desde nuestro desde
argentina
estamos ecuador-colombia ahora vamos
hasta argentina allí daniel campo line y
dice saludos desde el mundo
danielle gusto el fiel daniel cámpora y
qué bueno que nos están siguiendo tanta
gente desde tantos lugares y bueno yo
por mi parte tengo un mensaje que nos
envía michael show sobre el tema a
latinoamericanos en que ve quiénes son y
nos dice sería interesante de saber el
impacto de raza de personas latinas en
quebec y el resto de canadá en
particular cuántas personas dicen que
son víctimas de discriminación porque no
son blancos este es el mensaje que nos
hace llegar michael joe sobre el tema
sin más quería comentar sobre ese tema
creo que se puede contactar a la gente
que organizó esta encuesta sobre los
latinoamericanos en quebec tal vez
sugerirles una próxima encuesta con
algunas preguntas específicas para tener
más detalles sobre el hecho creo que
tiene una segunda etapa de esta
investigación efectivamente sí que
además que es fácil encontrar
información van a leer está en sitio y
la información está disponible también
necesito delante de quebec y montreal
uno de los responsables del proyecto ese
es un profesor que ha estado con
nosotros en muchas entrevistas armónica
y que busquen habitar money es quien
está justamente llevando adelante está
ese trabajo víctor armónico de origen
argentino también sin paloma si tengo un
comentario sobre el tema canadá critica
al resto de activistas sauditas arabia
saudita expulsa embajador canadiense y
federico sánchez dice creo que el
embajador canadiense debió ser más
prudente en sus declaraciones sobre el
tema estuve leyendo sobre el caso es la
primera vez que las señoras requeridas
investigación no sé a qué señora está
haciendo referencia pero no fue el
embajador canadiense que hizo
comentarios sobre los derechos humanos o
el respeto de los activistas de los
derechos humanos en arabia saudita fue
la representante de relaciones
exteriores del país que es cristiana
cristian field freeland y ella fue la
que hizo los comentarios y el gobierno
canadiense se mantiene en su postura
ellos dicen que siempre estarán a favor
de aquellos que defiendan los derechos
humanos y que el arresto de ciertas
personas en una manifestación
particularmente mujeres y la hermana de
un de un conocido bloguero no de origen
no canadiense pero dije en saudita pero
cuya familia vive aquí en canadá ésta
fue también arrestada entonces eso fue
criticado por el gobierno canadiense y
pues claro las relaciones están tensas
entre arabia saudita y canadá desde
entonces desde el domingo pasado
-grupo algún mensaje que quieras leer
pues sí aquí tenemos un mensaje muy bien
gastado bien estructurado de rodrigo
berger rodrigo vega gamarra y cuervo
nos exhibe desde desde colombia y él es
muy inspirado es realmente una carta que
como las cartas de antaño no hay que
vayan varios párrafos y un argumento
bien desarrollado y el justamente
comenta una noticia que dice que el fm
advierte que conflictos comerciales
hacen vulnerable a eeuu y rodrigo vega
dice el fmi dice que debido a la guerra
de aranceles los eeuu pueden sufrir una
de esas desaceleración en sus
exportaciones
eso no es determinante mientras se
asegure el mercado nacional para la
industria nacional y las empresas
nacionales se consoliden y crezcan y
queden en capacidad de producir para la
exportación de bienes de buena calidad a
precios competitivos es una cuestión de
tiempo y de espera mientras se consolida
internamente la economía nacional
estadounidense en una especie de
autarquía la política proteccionista de
washington es un apoyo del gobierno de
eeuu a su industria nacional todo
gobierno sensato tiene el deber de
proteger sus fuentes internas de empleo
y de producción
de no ser así los países entrarían en
recesión con una población desocupada
flotante mantenida por los subsidios
estatales por la economía informal y por
el delito además se convierten en países
compradores e improductivos que vivirían
endeudados para poder subsistir si bien
es cierto que los inversión de capitales
fortalece a las empresas también es
cierto que la jce esencia de existencia
de las plantas productivas mismas con la
ciencia y la tecnología al servicio de
ellas para su retroalimentación pues el
capital aparte de ser especulativo por
sí solo no se multiplica él dice
finalmente dice en fm que se elevaría la
incertidumbre y se dañaría la inversión
la duda siempre ha estado y la inversión
es dañada por múltiples factores crisis
política desastres naturales etcétera
que el hombre común no alcanza a
controlar en lo económico el ser humano
siempre ha vivido una especie de
fatalidad relativa de la cual siempre ha
sabido salir hoy por hoy todo parece
apuntar al fracaso de la política
neoliberal de apertura económica el
presi lo confirma dice finalmente en
esta larga carta
y cuervo desde colombia bueno ahí está
muy bien yo tengo por mi parte y antes
de pasar a los temas de la semana un
mensaje que nos envía willy y fabián y
bautista sobre el tema médico canadiense
dice que la diabetes tipo 2 es curable
nos dice willy que es de bolivia
preocupante el índice de diabéticos en
santa cruz de bolivia si pudiera
orientar más a nuestra población vía
este medio
o tal vez mediante vídeos clips bueno
habría que contactarse con el médico
directamente para para proponerle a él
en todo caso y ver si está interesado
realmente en enviar vídeos o cualquier
tipo de sugerencia que les pudiese
ayudar a superar esto que ustedes de
willy señala como un índice alto de
diabéticos en santa cruz de bolivia
porque será eso rojo porque tanto
diabético en esa zona porque lo que
bueno es lo que me sorprende lo que me
sorprendió mucho en santa cruz una
ciudad de una gracia más grande en
población en en bolivia es que nunca
había visto botellas tan grandes de
cocacola así son casi dos litros y medio
tres litros unas cosas enormes y no hay
no hay circunstancia en la cual esté
ausente es decir se consumen todas en
todo mente en todas partes y pues
seguramente han habido estudios en
méxico me acuerdo que demostraban
justamente que dejar de tomar este tipo
de bebidas azucaradas le reducía
consecuencias como la diabetes entonces
claro que hay que también recordar que
en algunas regiones no sé si en bolivia
es lo mismo
en algunas regiones de méxico es más
barato comprar coca cola que comprar
leche por ejemplo o incluso botellas de
agua y así yo creo que no hay problemas
de agua porque entonces
ríos pasan por la ciudad y también
seguramente también es la dieta no
porque hay muchos pasteles son muy ricos
bruselas fantásticos y una cosa que es
interesante en santa cruz alas es una
tradición que me gusta mucho y todavía
hay salones de té en que tú vas a las 45
de la tarde y tienes una panoplia de
exquisiteces hay dos cuñas veces por
ejemplo que es unos pasitos de que eso
tiene tradición inglesa mary de a las
cuatro y sí no
y yo creo que yo creo que había en todo
todos todas las culturas siempre tienen
tienen ritos cotidianos
entonces esa sobremesa o el célebre
almuerzo de domingo familiar que no
tienes que estar bueno las green es el
tuco siendo que ya no quedan menos de
diez minutos para terminar nuestra
emisión es decir el tiempo si nos va
como agua entre los dedos puesto como o
como tortillas bueno
cuáles son los tiempos en los que hemos
estado trabajando durante esta semana
que me refiero a los temas que ustedes
quieren proponer es en prioridad dentro
de todo lo que hemos trabajado esta
semana a aquellos que le proponen en
prioridad nuestros oyentes a nuestro
público en general para que accedan
prontamente a los mismos quien quiere
comenzar pues vayamos con esto
rojo podemos intercambiar el lugar bueno
freddy villanueva pero villanueva murió
hace 10 años hice un reportaje y una
entrevista sobre está sobre la muerte de
este chico de que en aquella época tenía
18 años y que murió por un por tiros de
un policía un policía de las del
servicio de policía de montreal entonces
recurrimos del norte en una zona de
montreal que es una de las zonas más
pobres del canadá completo no solamente
de montreal que tiene índices de
desempleo muy bajos niveles de perdón
índices de desempleo muy altos en
dificultades económicas importantes
entonces estuve conversando con
alejandra sara méndez quien tenía 20
años cuando sucedió la muerte de freddy
y que conoce muy bien este barrio de
montreal norte
alejandra me contó su me habló de sus
recuerdos claros sobre el evento como
tal me dijo también que no habían
cambiado mucho las cosas desde aquí
época que la discriminación que la
desigualdad que el desempleo siguen
siendo parte de la realidad cotidiana de
los jóvenes y de las familias que son en
mayoría inmigrantes en esa región del
asia y lo no porque no va a montar el
norte y parece una zona olvidada de
monte exactamente entonces cuando
entonces ahí explica toda esta realidad
desde lo que es su cuna porque ella
creció en montreal norte estos conocen
muy bien entonces es interesante
escuchar a una joven que tiene muchas
muchas ganas de que cambien las cosas
explicar este evento y explicar cómo
afectó a la población local el que este
joven que no estaba haciendo nada más
jugar dados con unos amigos en el parque
cuando res cuando fue digamos hubo una
intervención policial que fue mal cayó 6
siguió mal hubo una una de las personas
no quiso entregar los papeles bueno
entonces se armó una situación tensa
entre los policías y los chicos que
resultó en una fatalidad en la muerte de
freddy villanueva entonces diez años de
esta muerte y lo que eso significa para
mí
y para la gente los inmigrantes las
comunidades inmigrantes en canadá yo
recuerdo muy vivamente la conmoción que
creó ubicación en toda la sociedad y
parece mentira que hayan pasado diez
años
rufo tenías un mensaje creo sea que
daños que apoyen justamente que nos
envió un breve mensaje después de
saludarnos desde el mundo nos dice y si
no creo que exista hoy un país con una
política tan corrupta como la argentina
en mi punto y entonces ayer estaba yo
también en esta parte monte al norte y
pude también ver justamente esos
elementos y esta semana habrá un
reportaje también sólo uno puede
conversar con la madre de freddy
villanueva y es muy complicada es
compleja la situación difícil y lilian
villanueva es que estuvo presente en
todos los eventos relacionados con su
mismo el tema que propongo esta semana
es justamente una pregunta que nada
tiene o no derecho a pronunciarse sobre
los derechos humanos en arabia saudita
porque eso fue lo que irritó a la
monarquía que se rige a partir de la ley
de la sharía y además de
de expulsar al embajador canadiense le
dieron 24 horas para beso directa
también decidió retirar a los
estudiantes saudíes en canadá retirar a
los pacientes saudíes está recibiendo
atención médica acá y también está en
tela de juicio esta está casi en saber
si continúan este negocio de 15 mil
millones de dólares por la compra de
vehículos de combate que el ejército de
canadá estaba vendiendo a arabia saudita
entonces el profesor daniel turp quien
es un enseña derecho a la fruta en olla
de montreal de la facultad de derecho el
dice concretamente que canadá si tiene
derecho de ser podemos inmiscuirnos
porque justamente desde 1948 canadá
participó en la redacción misma de la
declaración de naciones unidas o los
derechos humanos y los países si tienen
derecho a pronunciarse sobre los
derechos humanos en otros países ese es
en concreto su respuesta entonces hay
más detalles
el contexto de este enfrentamiento y el
concreto es que básicamente arabia
saudita y la impresión que hay es que
arar es auditar compra esos es con esos
carros militares lo que en el fondo
crees y el silencio de que nada en
materia de derechos humanos en esa en
esa monarquía bueno el reportaje está
disponibles ya en el sitio en internet
quien esté interesado en el tema
invitado entonces para que acceda al
mismo yo por mi parte les propongo una
entrevista que realicé ligado al tema
del chat
sainz de h&m team en español es un
el telescopio gigante ubicado en la
provincia de columbia británica en el
oeste canadiense que se está dedicando a
estudiar diversos tipos de señales
provenientes del espacio exterior de la
profundidad del espacio exterior
este time que es el canadian y lorgen
intensity mapping experimento o
experimento canadiense para el mapeo de
la intensidad del hidrógeno se propone
crear un mapa del hidrógeno en el
universo el hidrógeno es el elemento de
mayor presencia en todo el universo y
que emite ese gas señales sonoras que
son captadas por este telescopio y al
estudiar los rastros más antiguos de
hidrógeno en el universo o más lejanos
también se puede hacer una se puede
trazar un mapa de cuál sido la expansión
que ha seguido el universo y prever cuál
va a ser la expansión que seguirá en el
futuro que es un tema que está
comenzando a hablarse mucho y
preocupando a los científicos porque se
sabe que el universo se sigue
expandiendo y en
en caso eso va a tener consecuencias yo
hablé con un científico que es de manuel
fonseca que es investigador postdoctoral
de astronomía en la universidad mcgill
él participa de esa experiencia y el
tema saltó esta semana sobre todo cuando
se empezó a hablar de comunicaciones de
radio
provenientes del espacio exterior y la
sabiduría popular él siempre que se
habla de este tipo de temas enseguida
habla de mensajes enviados por los
alienígenas
hay una civilización inteligente en el
exterior que está intentando comunicar
en el que nosotros le pregunté a fonseca
si este es el caso me dijo que no pero
dejó abierta la puerta porque de hecho y
esa es una de las características
sobresalientes de este telescopio que ya
no tengo tiempo de dar detalles sobre el
funcionamiento que es maravilloso que es
realmente fantástico es maravilloso pero
este telescopio el time podría llegar a
detectar emisiones de mensajes mejor
dicho de potenciales supuestas
hipotéticas
civilizaciones alienígenas que estén en
el espacio programa sólo en el mensaje
antes de ese mensaje vamos a una
pequeñita cortina
[Música]
y entonces ahora sí vamos a ese mensaje
mí y ya pronto porque es de gaby ramírez
dice saludos desde toronto y pregunta
donde podemos consultar los reportajes
sobre freddy villanueva en el sitio
internet
rc y net punto o sea es diagonal es ese
porque es en español entonces en nuestro
sitio internet aquí pero ahí está el
material ya disponible para que ustedes
lo puedan consultar lamentablemente no
tenemos más tiempo les agradecemos a
todos ustedes la presencia los
despedimos a los que están siguiendo a
través de facebook
prometemos a todos estar aquí una vez
más la semana próxima muchas gracias a
todos y los dejamos entonces con la
música de na william en este caso
waiting esperando
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y si se quiera
[Música]
y entonces ahora sí